ah
pepper relish on your arancini very
playful cut through the richness add a
little levity i love that you really
know your food you could say it's the
only thing i'm allowed to talk about i'm
charles i work with captain holt i'm
viviane lovely i work with kevin no
v vivian ludley author of stone fruits
and stone stones foot of the paleolithic
era i'm a huge fan
it's got the best recipes for making
salads out of moss the trick is
you have to lean into the dirt taste
my last meal on earth that's a great
question
i'd go classic french
orderlon
tiny songbird eaten in a single bite
bones and all an open defiance of god
it's illegal to consume more alone but i
actually got academic dispensation to
eat one once
the beak very crunchy that is literally
the sexiest thing anyone has ever said
how were you single
you're not seeing anyone
no
there's nobody in my life
sort of a sad thing to wink about i
realize now
are you supposed to be babysitting gina
it doesn't need my help she's over there
dazzling some psychologists all men are
at least 30 attracted to me my mother
cried the day i was born because she
knew she would never be better than me
at any given moment i'm thinking about
one thing richard dreyfuss hunkered over
eating dog food i feel like i'm the
paris of people complete overlap of ego
and id it's been theorized but i never
thought i'd see it i'm exquisite
i can't believe i'm frenching in the
closet i feel like a teenager i feel
like i'm 40 again chewing this she's a
leaf
it'll give her kissing umami flavor
[Music]
delicious
[Music]
[Applause]
neat sweater ugh did you tell jake yet
nope
really you told him about his own
surprise party mm-hmm first chance i got
but i had tons of chances to tell them
about what happened six months ago and i
didn't why not i didn't want to hurt
your feelings no pump the brakes charles
because i'm terrified of you and what
you'll do to me
oh that's sweet well then
sounds like our nightmare is finally
over
ah
what
thank you for coming i wasn't sure if
you'd get my message charles it was kind
of hard to miss
oh god
i didn't know what to do you said we
weren't allowed to talk at work now that
we're knocking boots oh gross listen my
ex-wife's throwing an engagement party
this weekend and i was wondering if you
wanted to go as friends no charles just
because we have secret shameful sex does
not mean we are friends i get friends
let's go as bone bros
i didn't strike you when you said
knocking boots but bone bros
i cannot abide
come on charles you gotta have something
weird and tragic going on nope not
unless you call hooking up with a girl
at a funeral weird and tragic home run
her name is lieutenant singh she's super
hot we were seated next to each other
two funerals ago and there was hard eye
contact all through danny boy last
funeral we made out in parking lot this
time
something nulty this way comes
what do you even know about this person
oh we don't know anything about each
other she says she likes that about us
it's just pure animal attraction this is
creepy and unlike you even know her
first name oh um do animals and wild
know each other's names
look all i know is charles boyle is
going to that funeral and he's going to
put the bone back in boneyard
ooh charles your jump off is here hello
detective hello lieutenants real tragic
about the captain yes real tragic i like
the way your butt looks today i've been
doing lunges in the shower well this got
upsetting real quick i want to live in
this moment forever i got us a motel
room across the street meet me there in
15 minutes
i'll meet you all right m-e-a-t
still think it's creepy
yes
charles it is not like you to have sex
with a total stranger really tell it to
me in an hour when we've had sex 23
times excuse me is that takiyaki yeah
from senka right down the street oh i
love that place the chef lets me take
octopus hearts home for my dogs oh lucky
how many dogs you have oh too many three
that's how many i have oh all right wait
uh quick question how do you keep them
off the bed
i gave up i sleep on the floor me too
it's better for your back
wow well nice meeting you
what are you doing she's walking away i
got nervous she eats octopus balls angie
slips on the floor she's the perfect
woman god
sorry i was aiming at somebody else but
now that i have your attention charles
he was naming out a terrible criminal he
probably saved the world do you want to
have a takoyaki at the on on the bench
over there sure i was hoping he'd ask
my work here is done
oh still fish oh god hey
where'd she go you guys were hitting it
off i half expected to see you sitting
in her lap by now she is amazing her
palette is wide and deep gross and at
one point when she wasn't looking i
snuck a whiff of her hair of course she
did she uses one of my top three
shampoos tahitian coconut extra lather
sounds good boy'd get her number oh we
lost track of time she had to go back
into court when she's done
i'm gonna ask her out oh okay okay so
what's the plan going straight from here
to the spa couple's massage okay seems a
little intense but given how your other
weirdness lined up i say go for it
oh here she comes whoa okay how do i
look you look great i've got a good
feeling about this ah
genevieve i know we just met and i don't
want to be too forward charles sometimes
you just get a feeling about a person
charles i got that feeling about you i
like you charles looked down tonight oh
shoot they just gave me 10 years in
prison
[Music]
she didn't say no
interesting yeah something definitely
doesn't add up
did you know there's a sausage you can
drink
what are you even talking about the case
oh we got distracted oh she has an
amazing tongue strong supple great bud
density okay i'm gonna take over the
question yeah i'm too close to this
disgusting eating habits hi genevieve
i'm just gonna ask you a couple of
questions now and detective boyle will
just sit there and keep waving at you i
guess
case closed justice served peralta
amazing oh god
your ex-wife is here eleanor
the destroyer of worlds
why maybe it's nothing bad maybe some of
your mail got sent to her house oh god i
hope not if that happened she would be
livid oh well just don't assume the
worst that's all i'm saying i don't want
you to bring up the mail thing i don't
hello chunk
heard you want your sperm you're gonna
have to go through me oh no this is way
worse than the male thing what male
thing nothing there's no male thing
there's no male thing but it's my sperm
how did you even find out i wanted it
because it counts under my name storage
facility called me saying that you were
looking to make a withdrawal so i went
ahead and withdrew it for you
i have all of your spur but you don't
even care about it eleanor
i mean remember oh hey charles i'll
never have a baby with you because i
don't love you and a child's not gonna
fix that oof when we started doing the
silly voice i thought it was gonna be
more fun but it wasn't i do not want
your dna i want something else i hit
some dumb ass with my car now he's suing
me
what i want is for you to use your badge
and your gun to intimidate him into
dropping the case wow that is
so very illegal he's not doing that i
don't care you have 48 hours
to do so or i'm gonna take your sperm
and i'm gonna dump it into the east
river please don't do that and there
will never be the possibility
of a little
pie-faced charles boyle jr proud of it
it's me
she can't do that can she do that stay
calm we're gonna talk to a lawyer and
get a professional opinion damn
i can't believe you signed this contract
the sperm is her legal possession it
also says that she and i quote owns your
dignity you initialled right next to
them
you